I want to talk about former new york
city mayor Rudolph Giuliani some people
say Rudolph and I say Rudolph because
there is an L at the end there I would
do that it's a very harsh shell but it's
an L nonetheless yeah up former NYC
Mayor Giuliani a trump supporter said
yesterday that there weren't terror
attacks on US soil prior to Barack Obama
being president now this is the guy this
is mr. noun verb 911 as I forget who it
was I think Joe Biden described him he
is known for talking about 911 in
basically every conversation he was in
Youngstown Ohio yesterday where the
david pakman show airs on TV by the way
a long time affiliate in youngstown ohio
at a trump rally here's what he had to
say under those eight years before Obama
came along we didn't have any successful
radical Islamic terrorist attack in the
United States they all started when up
Clinton and Obama got into office this
is the guy who ran an entire
presidential campaign in 2008 on the
premise that he was mayor of New York
City on 911 he's used 911 time and time
again for his own political gain but now
all of a sudden Obama apparently
personally invented Islamic terrorism in
the United States this is a very common
theme among uh among the right and that
is that uh George Bush was fantastic
because after 911 there were no more
attacks and and in every single case
when you talk to these people 911
doesn't count it's as if it didn't
happen how can you even say this with a
straight face because every 2016 voter
was alive on 911 now yes some were three
years old at the time admittedly but
does Giuliani think maybe people won't
remember that or is it going back to
this implicit other than and after 911
we were just completely safe from
radical Islamic terror under george w
bush which of course also ignores that
some very close allies of the United
States were devastated by radical
Islamic terror but all of a sudden what
happens outside of our borders doesn't
seem to matter even if
to our friends when it's the score
political points and to say that uh the
foreign policy decisions of George Bush
and Dick Cheney had nothing to do with
uh subsequent terrorist attacks yeah is
false that definitely had something to
do with it I'm not putting all the blame
on those decisions up when you'd I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com slash david support our
show reduce your carbon emissions and
you're spending on cars sign up at join
zipcar dot-com slash david